>> B Bret: LAWYERS FOR THE U.S.
ARE ASKG JUDGES OF THE
UNITED NATIONS HIGHEST COURT TO
DISMISS A CASE BROUGHT BY AROUND
SEEKING TO LIST SANCTIONS.
AN ATTORNEY SAYS PENALTIES ARE
VITAL TO THE U.S. EFFORT TO
CONTAIN IRAN’S NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
TONIGHT, AND LOOK AT HOW IRAN IS
BEING BLAMED FOR A POSSIBLE PLOT
AGAINST AN AMERICAN DIPLOMAT.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER.
>> FOX NEWS LEARNING NEW DETAILS
ABOUT AROUND ALLEGEDLY MOWING
OVER IN AN ATTEMPT TO
ASSASSINATE THE DIPLOMAT TO
SOUTH AMERICA
DELOF SOUTH AFRICA.
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
REPORTS SAY IT’S CREDIBLE AND
THEY TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
AT THE PLOT IS ONE OF SEVERAL
TEHRAN IS CONSIDERING TO
RETALIATE AGAINST THE U.S. FOR
THE JANUARY KILLING OF THE TOP
GENERAL DURING A TRIP TO BAGHDAD
BAGHDAD.
HE COMMENDED THE ELITE FORCE
THAT THE U.S. DESIGNATED A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
>> HE WAS PLOTTING IMMANENCE AND
SENATOR ATTACK ON MILITARY
PERSONNEL.
>> THE HUNT INTENSIFIED LAST
JUNE AFTER IRAN SHUT DOWN A U.S.
DRONE.
DECEMBER, THE U.S. CLAIMED THE
PROXY FORCES STORMED THE
AMERICAN EMBASSY IN IRAQ.
THE SAME MONTH, THE REGIME
LAUNCHED A SERIES OF ATTACKS ON
U.S. MILITARY BASES IN IRAQ THAT
LASTED THROUGH THE NEW YEAR.
>> WE TOOK ACTION LAST NIGHT TO
STOP A WAR.
>> SIX MONTHS LATER, THE IRANIAN
REGIME ISSUED A ARREST WARRANT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A CLOSE FRIEND OF THE PRESIDENT
WHO’S BEEN SERVING IN TOP
DIPLOMATS IN THE AFRICAN NATIONS
FOR LESS THAN A YEAR.
RECENT MONTHS, SHE FOCUSED
LARGELY ON COVID RELATED AID
PROJECTS IN HER COUNTRY WHILE
THE U.S. DOESN’T HAVE FORMAL
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS WITH
TEHRAN, SOUTH AFRICA DOES.
IF POLITICAL REPORTING TODAY THE
IRANIAN EMBASSY THERE IS
INVOLVED IN THE ALLEGED PLOT.
TONIGHT THE FOREIGN MINISTRY IS
REFUTING THE REPORTING BUT
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT IN
THE PAST AROUND AND COOKED UP
SIMILAR PLOTS AND THAT THERE IS